let's talk about owning nothing and
being happy yes we have the story from
wired it's actually from a month ago but
it gets into the core of right to repair
it says a fight over the right to repair
cars turns ugly in the wake of a voter
approved law subaru and kia dealers in
massachusetts have disabled systems that
allow remote starts and send maintenance
alerts
now i'm not super interested just in
that cause i don't talk about the bigger
picture but i think this shows an
interesting you know uh issue as it
pertains to these big corporations and
the rest of us who will eventually own
nothing and be happy i just like to
point out like your iphone
what is it you don't actually own the
software on you have a license to it
they could break oh you can keep the
phone but we'll brick it remotely
because we own the software and you lose
your license to it this is a problem
because we're losing ownership and
things we don't own movies anymore we
don't own the software on computers and
when it comes to you actually buying a
phone
you can't even fix it without the
company what they're they're denying
your warranties you want so lewis you're
actually the right to repair guy right
yeah i try to be all right so tell us
what's going on with this and uh yeah
what's what's up with what this means
there was a 2012 uh law that was passed
in massachusetts where the the
automotive manufacturers would have to
give independent dealer independent
mechanics access to what's needed to be
able to repair your car so diagnostic
software and everything else you'd have
to make that available to them and there
was one loophole in it with regard to
wireless so there was a so if you are
doing all this stuff wirelessly then you
won't have to deal with that law so they
were trying to close that loophole
before everything winds up being done
wirelessly so that they don't get locked
out and there was a ballot initiative
and i believe it was 75 in favor 25
percent opposed and a group called
coalition get rid of the wireless
loophole or what well to pass this so
that there wouldn't be any sort of
loopholes that you'd still be able to
and the idea that they're saying is that
people now if you allow these
independent mechanics to be able to use
diagnostic software on the car that they
are and also they were going to to
create an open some sort of open data
protocol so that they would be able to
access it that they would then be able
to follow you to a garage and sexually
assault you wait what well there were a
bunch of commercials done where there
was a woman walking to her car and it
was a nice very very dark blue lighting
and she's getting into her car and this
is scary music is playing and right is
before she opens her car window she
looks behind herself and she's about to
get smacked by some dude and the
implication is that that dude is the car
mechanic these videos our mechanic was
kidnapping women and then there was
another one where this car mechanic is
slowly walking up on the garage this
woman is slowly closing the garage door
and he opens it up and then he walks
into her home and you hear the scary
music playing in the background the
implications that's the dude that fixes
your car so one of this was paid for by
ford honda nissan general motors and
toyota they each contributed four to
five million dollars for those
commercials they were all scrubbed from
the internet entirely because why would
you want to be associated with this
after you lose but i archived them on my
channel and uh there was um and that's
what they were doing to try to get
people to vote against it is there a way
to search for this real quick while
you're talking it's on my channel i
think it's uh
right i forget the title of my own video
which is really really remember
it's somewhere on my channel but if you
look for uh
if you if you just look for the ballot
initiative actually what do you search
for i don't know
right to repair sexual assault probably
is what how long ago was it this was in
august of 2020. okay so not too long ago
yeah this was august 2020 that i made
that video and i i put the video there
and you can't find it anymore and their
website is completely scrubbed they were
trying to scare your average voter into
believing that if independents are able
to work on your car that they'll be able
to assault you in a parking lot and
break into your home called lobbyist
supply right to repair helps domestic
abusers push racism yeah that's it
that's it that's it yeah and they also
they also said it was raised obvious
imply right to repair if you searched
that yeah they also said it was racist
which is something we got accused of in
this very state the right to repair was
racist yeah i got accused of that
literally two weeks ago uh it's in this
video so if you fast forward to a minute
there you go thank you wow let's play
this
all right
personal data stored in your vehicle
domestic violence advocates say a sexual
predator could use the data to stalk
their victims
pinpoint exactly where you are whether
you are alone
even take control of your vehicle
vote no
same thing with onstar but she should be
looking behind herself
the whole time she's walking through
that place alone firstly yeah and then
well like you'd hear what steps yeah
really yeah so they they're looking to
overturn that ballot initiative and
they've been in court for this entire
time and the judge is actually starting
to get kind of aggravated with their
arguments and what they were saying
because they said it's impossible for us
to comply with this yet then kia and
subaru complied by simply disabling
their wireless systems altogether which
is it's a discussion as to whether
that's complying with it or evading it
but it aggravated the judge so the judge
is likely gonna there's a good chance
that this winds up getting held up and
uh yeah i mean if you buy a car you
should be able to fix it you should be
able to get access to the diagnostic
tools there shouldn't be something where
it's like dealing with apple where you
if you want to be able to diagnose it
you have to wait for somebody to get a
stolen schematic off of a truck in china
somewhere so that you could fix the 40
000 car that you want i just want to
point out the absurdity of them trying
to play the racism angle where it's just
like they're probably sitting in a room
like how can we get people to not be
okay with this ooh call them racists
that that that actually worked so in
march of 2016 in march of 2020 there was
a right to repair bill hearing in in
maryland and there was one person who
said you know this bill talks about
making source code available which it
doesn't it doesn't mention source code
once that's never in the bill and i said
you know this and he said that well you
know by the way viruses don't just
appear out of nowhere they appear
because people have access to the source
code you could immediately hear every
single person who was a linux developer
or systems administrator who knows that
over 60 of the internet is run on linux
which is open source like just banging
their head against the wall listing case
so i did a video
saying with the testimony because i went
there to record it and i also testified
in this hearing to explain why this was
wrong and i listened to that video i've
listed that video like a hundred times
since i did it i don't hear anything
racist in it i try to channel my own
like ibramex kendi or
you know robin d'angelo to try to figure
out what i could have said or done that
was wrong and i don't see it even my
comments i read through it had 300
comments at the time it was a it was uh
this is who's stopping right to repair
in maryland from march of 2020 and i it
there's nothing racist in it there are a
lot of comments saying this politician
is a [ __ ] wow i can't believe this guy
got elected what an idiot which is
normal political discourse in our
country regardless of race but he had
said the re so when we hired a lobbyist
in that state they said that that was a
racist video and that's why they weren't
going to consider right to repair so
then the lobbyist said well listen my
client is willing to personally come
down here on a trip you know uh come to
your office and apologize and discuss
anything with you like no don't worry
about water under the bridge then two
weeks ago they say oh yeah there was a
very racist video that was done and i'm
not i'm not going to consider this bill
and it's like
like
really and i've i've literally read
through every single comment every
single one of the 300 comments because
you'll see there there are comments
sections on youtube where they'll say
you know oh that like look at that set
of runners where the runner means jogger
in jogger means n-word for somebody that
doesn't actually want to say it
none of it it was it was clean as can be
just idiot dumbass whatever they're
lying bro
and and but the thing is it worked right
because that bill is gone but this is
what i was talking about middle ground
people you think average middle ground
people would if you talk to them and
explain to them what happened they'd be
on your side i don't know a single
left-wing person that watched that video
of what he was claiming that even agree
with him even people that i know that
are larry left-wing was like that that's
full of it what was the actual client so
who's the politician who who's like not
getting on board ct wilson is he's a
democrat or a republican he is all right
well
i've been the thing is right to repair
has been screwed over by republicans
democrats and libertarians in almost
every single state libertarians yes okay
so in a breath that's surprising no
in the browser republican i get you know
democrat i get in nebraska in 2015 in
2017 there was a senator bob crist who
agreed to meet with all of us the day of
the hearing and then he called off the
hearing and then he he didn't he wasn't
interested in it uh
mueller rollback kim roback who was an
att lobbyist donated three thousand
dollars i thought that that's nothing
maybe the cost of living is different in
nebraska and that's all it takes but
yeah he was gonna meet with us he called
it off last minute you go to follow the
money.org and that day you see uh kim
roback of the atm t who used to be
lieutenant governor who was an atc
lobbyist who testified against the bill
gave him money uh ernie chambers this is
interesting ernie chambers who is a very
left-leaning democrat and if you go to
followthemoney.org actually he has no
there's no company giving him money he
is purely fund-raised by his neighbors
and everybody going door-to-door
knocking him people giving him a dollar
he said and i quote to consider this
bill strike all contents from the bill
and write in the following better luck
next year and then he started laughing
at us what then he started laughing at
us laura epp who was a libertarian sat
next to him also laughed by the way she
was voted out of office by tom brandt no
she she was beat out of office by tom
brandt who is a republican who was a
farmer who won an election based on
right to repair in washington state the
democrats voted for it every single
person who voted against right to repair
who didn't want it to move forward was a
republican in washington state the
interesting thing is in nebraska this
time around
it was actually urban democrats that
voted for right to repair and rural
republicans that were endorsed by the
nebraska farm bureau that voted against
it and a part of me wonders is this just
them trolling are they just trying to
say like are they trying to actually get
the rural vote and say listen you guys
see us all as city slickers they're
voting against you being able to fix
your own tractor we don't even know what
a tractor is and we're voting for it so
why don't you consider voting but in
every state it's been very eclectic who
supports it and who declines who denies
it
it's a total coin toss you know i'm
willing to bet it has a lot to do with
you know for farmers you've got a lot of
these big companies
it's not so much the farmers is the
politician and they say we're gonna run
ads against you and make you look as bad
as possible to every one of your
constituents you know the amount of
money we will dump into destroying you
you will never compete with and they say
okay i'm not gonna i'm not gonna bother
that's another thing that's been very
interesting is figuring out who is for
this and who is against this so when i
started actually when i did the
fundraiser last year i wanted to do a
ballot initiative in the state of
massachusetts that was my goal to try
and get it passed by people and just
bypass this entire disgusting process
altogether i said if i raise three to
six million i'll do it if i don't i'll
just do traditional lobbying to try to
get something passed in the state so
there's a state where i am try i we
introduced a bill that does not exclude
farm equipment and there was someone who
was asking to be excluded from farm
equipment and it was a farm bureau now
this is no so i have a conference so i i
get an email from uh that's from my
lobbyist uh i would have not shared but
at this point i don't care because i got
called racist by senators in the state
and the bill got killed anyway he said
you probably shouldn't share this
because if you share stuff like this do
you want to get a bill passed or do you
just want to stir up stuff it's like
well i didn't get a bill passed doing it
your way anyway so i get in i see an
email saying it's still a tough issue to
address our problem isn't a non-ability
to repair our own equipment but more
lack of service providers and key times
of the year key part most farmers don't
have or care to have the knowledge or
the equipment to repair their own
equipment so it's a service provider
issue
tell that to a farmer tell it to a
farmer that most farmers don't have the
knowledge or the ability to repair their
own stuff well farmers are all dumb so
no but this is somebody that represents
farmers that is saying this this is
somebody from a farm bureau so i say
listen i can't let this go i know i'm
supposed to let this go i can't let this
go i give the guy a call it's like yo
you emailed my lobbyist who i hired i
know that you know that he was going to
send this to me i am i you know i grew
up in brooklyn i've never been on a farm
in my life so if i show up to a state
and i start advocating for right to
repair and then we remove agriculture
from the bill that's going to look like
this new york city per city slick or
whatever is is trying to screw over
farmers do you want to see how it looks
for me now you're the one who's asking
to be removed from the bill and you're
saying if you're not removing the bill
that you're probably going to ask to be
removed and that's going to be awkward
so we should ask to be removed so i need
you to understand how bad this would
look for me if i was to remove it can
you explain why you want to be removed
from this bill and can you explain how i
can explain in a pr friendly way why it
is you're asking to be removed when
you're saying that you support farmers
and can you please explain this line
that you told me most farmers don't have
or care to have the knowledge of the
equipment to repair their own equipment
and the answer that i got was
in my opinion garbage so there's there's
this is politics man you look if you if
you play it honest and and honorable
you'll get stampeded over and crushed by
the people who are willing to lie cheers
i got stampeded i absolutely got
stampede and the thing is
the idea you can't share this if you
share that then you'll look bad i didn't
share it i did exactly
i did exactly what i was supposed to do
and then it was caring and then you know
this is it did anything win no it wasn't
going to win anyway but
i like i like sharing the details i like
letting people know i want people to
know exactly who's group absolutely and
i'm doing that every single chance that
i get in every single state i'm point
like with nebraska i pointed out by the
way here all the people that are
endorsed by the farm bureau here are all
the people that voted against it do you
see that all the people that voted
against it are endorsed by the farm
bureau so what you know what you're
proposing is like simple that people who
say by a tractor are allowed to fix
their own tractor i'm saying that make
available the diagnostics the schematics
and the tools at a fair and reasonable
price that you make available to your
own dealers or technicians so if you
sell this if you sell the software
package to a dealer for 5 000 let them
buy it for 5000. if you sell if if you
sell this schematic for you know 500
dollars or this this manual for 500
sell it to the independent for 500 right
now i rely for my business on stuff that
fell off the back of a truck it's all
like the the process that i go through
to get access to screens and ships my my
customers think that i just go to
mouser.com and i just buy everything
that i want they have no idea the
nicolas cage lord of war supply chain
ridiculous nonsense that happens in the
background so that i could get them a
computer screen but there's yeah like
this this this plays into phones and
stuff as well right
like it goes yeah it's with almost
everything and you know one of the
things that drives me nuts is when
people say just don't buy apple and
it'll go away i talk about apple
products because that's what i fix but
show me a smartphone where you can get
the schematic from the company even
fairphone who says they support right to
repair will not give you a schematic for
any amount of money what about freedom
freedom phone freedom yeah freedom fund
i think the only thing that would give
you i think because they buy it third
party i haven't double checked if this
is the case but i think pine phone will
but if you use it it is
they're a great company it's a bit far
from the experience the experience that
you'll get if you buy you know a s10 e
or uh or an iphone 10 or anything like
that they're getting there but they're
but like there's no if you want to have
access to things like this you really
have to give up the ability to live in a
modern society you know you can't get a
schematic to your monitor you can't buy
like you can't buy chips to a lot of the
things that you want to and is the is
the challenge though like copyright
a lot of ip yeah what they'll say is
they'll say that it's that it is a an
intellectual property issue but here's
the actual issue i think it is i don't
think it's an issue of if we release the
schematic somebody else will reproduce
our product because if you go to
venafix.com or you know notebook squad
or any of these places you'll be you
could spend 20 bucks and get access to
all the schematics well not just that
i'm pretty sure every major phone
company buys every brand new phone and
just opens it and goes oh i think here's
i think here's the issue they're afraid
if the schematics get out that it won't
be that that users or other companies
will copy their technology but rather
it'll show up that they were already
copying everybody to begin with i'm sir
i think that's a part of it so for
instance let's say you pay a company and
this is this is my speculation based on
what i've heard from people in the
industry that i don't want to uh give
their name out because
they're probably doing this but
they let's say you ask company in china
uh you know we want a lot we want a
laptop motherboard with these
specifications and this chipset and this
blah blah blah blah blah that company
that's actually doing everything in
taiwan or korea or china are they going
to start from scratch to make it just
for you or are they going to say well
dell or lenovo contracted us to make
this control c control v
here you go
so there's a so there's a lot of
technology out there where you it
probably is a direct copy and paste of
somebody else's thing and especially in
china yeah because they're doing it
because they don't care but here our
laws say that we care so if you keep the
schematic and everything private you
can't really see that versus if you make
it public then maybe it's a little bit
more easy to see that wait you copy my
bluetooth circuit you copied this
circuit or something like that that's my
best case but the like you used to be if
you bought a radio or you bought a
television you bought
all these any of this different stuff
you would open it and there'd be a
schematic on the back of it that shows
everything's put together and you could
buy manuals to it i mean you know even
for the uh you know for the all four
computers back in the day they used to
come with schematics and manuals that
show you how to fix everything and the
argument that gets used now is security
and safety that we that we would be less
secure and less safe but were people
like blowing themselves up fixing their
toasters 50 years ago no we had a much
more freedom oriented mindset back then
did you say that onstar i felt like i
talked over you were talking about
onstar can track where people are in
their cars and like you were saying with
this this propaganda commercial that if
a woman's walk into her car in the
middle of night people from onstar know
that yeah i mean if i'm if i'm gonna
like i'm not gonna spend five thousand
dollars for all these different tools if
i'm if i want to abuse my wife i'm not
gonna do all of this i'm probably just
gonna toss an air tag under the mattress
or something matter something yeah yeah
not that i do that not quite not only
that i mean a lot of these there's
there's a million and one ways to track
vehicles there are so many ways to track
people that are easier than hacking into
the open data system in your cars
get you know get on stuff complicated
ways to track somebody no it's
ridiculous and again this is designed to
scare you and the thing that a lot of
people don't get is a lot of people will
say tesla is anti-repair in many ways
true however who funded this ford
general motors toyota nissan and honda
and the reason that all the stuff was
scrubbed from the internet right after
they lost is because they don't want to
have that anti-repair reputation they
don't want to be known as the company
that associated being sexually assaulted
with uh with having a car repaired but
they should be because they paid for
this yeah tesla open sourced all their
patents i don't know all our patent are
belong to you tesla.com from 2019 yeah
elon's uh john's a weird guy he's a
funny dude um also if he does a lot of
good stuff but he's also a very strange
man i love him yeah open source
ecology.org if you guys ever seen this
it's mark i think it's pronounced marcin
jakubowski is his name but he's
basically created all these farm all
this farm equipment and he's
open-sourced all the patents of how to
build them repair them but you can build
them and do them yourself very maybe you
know what's funny is like we have to
make fun of the great reset you will own
nothing and you will be happy
you know you've heard that right i have
yeah what if the you will owe nothing is
because everything's like open source
and available for you to create your own
you know what i mean molecular printing
like let's think about that i guess in
that reality you would own stuff you'd
own what you made i don't think that was
meant as nefarious as they said it when
they actually said it i think the part
of it was you used to have a record
collection now you're going to be happy
with just you know you you search for a
song like you you just type it in and it
automatically starts playing for you
that type of thing but that's bad but
that coincided really bad the thing is
that statement and that trend of you
just having access to everything
immediately at your fingertips whether
it's an uber for a car or music just so
happens to coincide with a second
separate trend where every single
company is doing everything they can to
make things unrepairable because there's
more money to be made by buying a new
one it is nefarious to say
you used to have record collection now
you have it on your phone because they
can say you're a naughty boy so we've
banned you from music forever you could
you you know use the record collection
they could come out and be like you're
you're you're a jerk and nobody likes
you so you can't come to the record
store anymore and they'd be like well i
got a big old pile of records right here
this i got those now spotify will just
be like we're gonna ban you like i'll
tell you this man lee camp right you
ever hear of lee camp no he's like a
lefty guy he worked for rt he had a
podcast a personal podcast it wasn't
through rt and it got deleted from
spotify because
he worked for rt that's redacted tonight
right redacted tonight was was deleted
off of uh youtube he had another show on
on on spotify that got purged it was
different for being for for working for
our russian outlet or whatever and uh
but the point is that's that's a
different kind of suspension
you could be
booted off you know itunes and then you
have no music on itunes and you say okay
maybe spotify but if they all coordinate
like they do with alex jones it is a
really really bad thing for them to be
like you will own nothing and you will
be happy yeah you're happy until like in
that was it black mirror where they
blocked someone in real life yeah they
just saw a silhouette walking around
i think that what they meant with that
statement is that you're going to use
more services than own things i would
prefer to own things than have services
myself that's my preference but i think
that's that's a separate thing then they
can then what's happening now which is
everything that you buy winds up
becoming disposable but it but i i'm
glad that that statement exists and that
so many people are aggravated at that
statement because it's going to cause
people to be more sensitive to when you
buy something and there's you know
there's a five dollar trip in your three
thousand dollar macbook that dies and
they tell the company that makes it not
to sell it to anybody do you actually
own what you buy if you cannot buy any
of the components necessary to repair it
because the company goes out of their
way to stop you from doing so like if i
go to intersil and i try to buy a chip
that i could have bought ten years ago
i'm not allowed to they'll say we can
only sell to people who are on this
approved vendor list uh renaissance
electronics say we can only sell and
let's approve underlist same with texas
instruments if that's the case do you
actually own anything
i think it's uh
are you leasing it are you leasing that
tablet until it dies and you own it
technically you own you own an
unrepairable piece of machinery i guess
yeah because the life cycles i love a
lot of this i mean you know a lot of
these devices will die within a year or
two that's intentional this planned
obsolescence thing are they doing this
on purpose i think some of it is just
the way like the way people use things
now but also the fact that i mean if you
plug it if you plug a charger into a
macbook into something weird with your
electrical uh circuitry in your house or
something it'll just blow a cd 3217 chip
and it'll be dead you didn't do anything
wrong you don't even have to use a
knock-off charger for to happen
this is like a very very common repair
we get it every single day really yeah
and there's something that i have to do
to get that chip that i can't say on
stream but it's but it's like it's
stupid that's nefarious now what you're
doing with that's nefarious that you
wouldn't be able to talk about it openly
i mean if it's a proprietary fix you
mean that you do not have a priority
fixed i can't say how we get access to
some of these things in legally
it's not legal that's incredible but
it's it's really like it's just dumb
that things have to be that way
and the thing is people will say well
you're only advocating for right to
repair because it helps your business
it's like no it's the opposite when you
have 1 million youtube subscribers you
can say you know oh man if only i had
this chip i could do this repair and i
will get a box for with no return
address or whatever with like a spool of
chips and say thank you for the youtube
videos yeah
people that started someone rid me of
this priest and the priest is just gone
huh yeah the people who started where i
did 10 years ago they can't do that
they're like when i when i where i
started 10 years ago they can't do that
they don't have the ability to say
something like that and just have some
contact reach out to them that allows
them to get access to all the things
that i can yeah like i'm doing this for
the people that started where i did
because i want them to have a path to
get where i am now like i started doing
this when i had 200 in my bank account 1
000 in credit card debt and didn't you
know i just dropped out of college and i
was able to start a store and you know
get 12 employees have a decent quality
of life and i want everybody else to be
able to do that but that path is that
bridge that i cross is slowly burning
away behind me i agree man completely
yeah you know i want to believe that if
you if you just work hard and dedicate
yourself but uh i mean looking at
youtube they're pulling up the ladder
behind us everybody they're making it
harder and harder for people to have
people of merit aren't going to be able
to make it in i think you know kind of
just to do a quick shift we're gonna
super chats when it comes to pulling up
the ladder behind it as far as it goes
with media
i think
when when youtube started when the
internet was prominent meritocracy was
the law of the land if you made good
stuff that people wanted to see you you
would do well and meritocracy doesn't
mean good content people like started
posting boobies you know all over
youtube and it worked really well for
their channels and made them huge
youtube eventually started getting rid
of this and saying now we should just
choose who wins and who loses that way
we have control of the situation so the
ladder's been pulled up behind everybody
i i that's why i recommend people now
like if you're going to start a channel
started on rumble or mines or mines some
new network yeah you've got a real
chance at meritocracy on a new platform
that you want on youtube are people
actually using them though that's the
biggest problem with new platforms yeah
they are like a bunch of people would
suggest that i use library and i i do
you know
uh but but when i actually opened up a
library channel nobody watches it but uh
rumble if you know uh
dan bongino gets got more views and has
more subscribers on rumble than in
youtube that's interesting and uh and
that's one of the reasons probably an
investor in it because he was driving a
lot of that growth for sure but you know
he's he's he's got a what like a
nationally syndicated radio show and
podcast that helped him build that up
yeah but i'm saying you know for you
right now you got you know 1.7 million
subscribers or whatever if you were to
jump over to rumble or mines you
wouldn't have as big of a platform but
if someone right now has nothing has no
followers whatsoever i'd say rumble you
know in addition
yeah what you're saying about
the right to repair and access to open
source machinery schematics and things
how do you feel about software code
like with proprietary networks i for
instance google
youtube something like that i've never
thought of the idea of making of
mandating that everything be open source
i like open source software i like
people when people make it available but
if you're going to make a device that
requires well let's give an example so
there was a microwave recently that i
forget made by electrolux and because it
was given a software update that didn't
work that microwave now thinks that it's
a steam oven and it doesn't turn on
because it thinks it's a steam oven now
why you have a microwave that connects
to wi-fi is beyond me why anybody
like they perfected the microwave over
everything that you could have in a
microwave like 40 years ago when they
put a clock in a microwave i think that
was that was the last update that you
needed but um if if something happens
like that even if you don't have access
to the source code should you be able to
have access to the rom because what you
need a service technician to come out to
your home to fix that why can't you fix
it yourself because you don't have
access to software so should that stuff
be made available for devices that
require it
that's that's an important question
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there
you